on Monday BuzzFeed headlined these eight
men owned as much wealth as half the
world this vital bit of information came
with this supporting facts courtesy of
BuzzFeed special correspondent James
ball and UK editorial developer Chris
Applegate quote the world's eight
richest men are worth four hundred and
twenty six billion dollars the world's
poorest three point seven billion people
together own 409 billion dollars
seventeen billion dollars less these
statistics came courtesy of Oxfam
BuzzFeed tuts quote the finding sheds
stark light on the scale of inequality
across the world with the figures also
revealing that the wealthiest 1% of the
population together own more than the
remaining 99 percent combined the eight
men who own as much as half the world
are Microsoft founder Bill Gates Zara
founder Amancio Ortega u2 US investor
Warren Buffett Carlos Slim Hilo owner of
Mexican conglomerate grupo Carso Amazon
founder Jeff Bezos Facebook founder Mark
Zuckerberg Oracle co-founder Larry
Ellison and businessman and former New
York City Mayor Michael Bloomberg Oxfam
which routinely stumps for global
redistribution ISM be wailed the health
divided the wealth divide said quote
well one in nine people on the planet
will go to bed hungry tonight
a small handful of billionaires have so
much wealth they would need several
lifetimes suspended the fact that a
super rich elite are able to prosper at
the expense of the rest of us at home
and overseas shows how warped our
economy has become inequality is not
only keeping millions of people trapped
in poverty it is fracturing our
societies and poisoning our politics
first off there is no indicator anywhere
in this report that the wealth of the
world's eight wealthiest men was
ill-gotten there is no record of them
enslaving people or robbing banks or
burning down rival businesses the reason
these people are rich is because they
have founded businesses that created
better products and services and engaged
in more consensual transactions than and
the other people on planet earth Bill
Gates's Microsoft's created repeated at
twelve thousand millionaires among his
employees Microsoft currently employs
more than a hundred thousand people
Microsoft employees have been given one
have given more than 1 billion dollars
to charity Microsoft products have made
millions of lives easier and better and
millions of businesses cheaper to run
the same is true for Amazon one of the
world's great companies certainly as a
consumer I benefit from Amazon every
single day it's true Zara my wife loves
it's for a facebook it's from Oracle
among others where exactly is the great
sin
Oxfam's implication seems to be that
wealth belongs to the collective and we
must therefore reallocate it hence their
language about a super-rich elite
prospering at our expense
but these rich people aren't prospering
at the expense of others since 1981 the
global extreme poverty rate has been
sliced in half meanwhile from 1979 to
2014 the upper-middle class in America
grew from 12% of the population to 30%
of the population America's poor are
doing better than the middle class in
most places on earth thanks to the
glories of free market economics and
here's what Pew Research said in 2015
quote the u.s. stands head and shoulders
above the rest of the world more than
half 56% of Americans were high income
by the global standard more than 32%
were upper-middle income in other words
almost 9 in 10 Americans had a standard
of living that was above the global
middle income standard only 7 percent of
people in the United States were middle
income 3% were low income and only 2%
were poor the quest for income
inequality is a fool's errand that's
because the only way to rectify
imbalances is to punish successful
risk-taking the reason that investors
make greater profits than those who do
the actual work is because the investor
takes the risk necessary in order to
create a profit margin with which to pay
those people
Oxfam neglects to mention where the
world's poorest people live according to
the World Bank two-thirds of the world's
poorest human beings live in India China
Nigeria Bangladesh and Congo the
Heritage Foundation index of economic
freedom ranks these countries thusly in
terms of their participation in free
markets and their governmental
dedication to rule of law and private
property rights India ranks 120th Congo
ranks 160 eighth China ranks 137 Nigeria
ranks 129th Bangladesh ranks 130 first
so Oxfam solution is to regulate markets
more a richer world relies on freer
markets both at home and abroad but the
foolish inconsistent focus on income
inequality merely provides cover for
policies that actually enhance human
suffering rather than mitigating it i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
so so glad that you could join us here
on Martin Luther King Day a great day
for America it's also a great day for me
yesterday it was my birthday so who to
me I'm now Christians second favorite 33
year old Jew
I'm 33 today so that's very exciting
among my favorite gifts my dad got me a
Louisville Slugger baseball bat which is
very exciting heading into 2017 I intend
to wrap it in wire and use it as I see
fit and and also my wife got me she got
a mug for herself that said I don't need
Google my husband knows everything she's
gonna take a picture of herself drinking
from that mug and put it on a mug for me
so that's very exciting I'm very excited
about that also it seems that the good
folks at the Daily wire Malthus and
Jonathan and Austin and the rest of the
crew Bailey and Cynthia everybody they
got me these wonderful gifts so let's
just open one right now let's see what's
in here I'm very excited to open these
gifts on air let's see what we've got
oh wow Wow yes it's just what I've
always wanted
it's an ad read thank you to blue apron
one of our sponsors for for sponsoring
the program blue apron fantastic service
have a lot of friends have a lot of
relatives who use blue apron boo apron
the way that it works is that they send
fresh ingredients to your house with the
recipe and all these meals are able to
be cooked in 40 minutes
or less the recipes apparently are all
fantastic that's what I've heard from
everybody who's tried a blue apron for
less than $10 per person per meal blue
apron delivers those seasonal recipes
along with pre portion ingredients to
make delicious home-cooked meal there's
variety you can choose from a variety of
new recipes every week or you can let
blue aprons qulet area team surprise you
the recipes are not repeated within a
year so you're never gonna get bored
which is great because at our house we
have like a weekly rotating menu and it
gets boring really really fast blue
apron make sure that doesn't happen
again they all have the step-by-step
easy-to-follow recipe and everything is
guaranteed for freshness check out this
week's menu and you get the first three
meals for free with free shipping if you
go to blue aprons com /up here's a big
thing in LA like everybody in LA is
using blue apron now which is which is
just fantastic blue apron calm slash
Shapiro you will love it everybody I
know who's tried it absolutely loves it
blue apron calm slash Shapiro so check
that out
Weidman is a better way to cook oh
thanks guys oh you got me a cupcake god
that's so nice look at that is it kosher
Wow a kosher cupcake well happy birthday
to me gang oh yeah that's right so that
means I won't go to jail this year woo
alright so now we can actually jump into
the news of there with all the birthday
all the birthday paraphernalia put aside
we can jump into jump into the news of
the day so the big news of the day
obviously its Martin Luther King Day and
we will get to how Democrats are
exploiting race because it's Martin
Luther King Day but I want to start that
with an article from guy named Oliver
Thomas ok Oliver Thomas writes this
piece for the for USA Today and the
piece is totally not so the piece is
titled this is why it's getting all
sorts of attention the piece was titled
White's killed MLK now we honor him ok
so I wasn't there but what me OK my
parents were around at that time one
them in fact there were lots of white
people around that time and it wasn't
those people actually it was just like
the guy who did it
but what is this thing really about it's
all about virtue signaling it's about
virtue signaling so what the piece says
is quote seems like every time dr. King
showed up somewhere things got torn up
or burned up so we killed him not me of
course I'm not a racist
but who thinks he is so we tried to fix
it made his birthday a national holiday
put him on a pedestal where we can honor
him and he can't poke us in the eye
this neglects a few kind of crucial
issues with regard to the civil rights
movement one lot of white Americans back
the civil rights movement which is why
it was successful it turns out that the
black population of the United States is
approximately 10% you know a lot of
other race a lies in order to make a
success if you are a minority group
that's just the reality of politics
ok second if you look at the faces in
the Selma March pretty diverse group and
it was Martin Luther King's recognition
I'm like Malcolm X early Malcolm X it
was Martin Luther King's recognition
that you actually needed to work with
people across the racial spectrum in
order to move forward with individual
civil rights that made him successful he
was successful not just because he was a
fantastic order and a really profound
thinker and on racial matters but
because he actually had the foresight to
reach out to people who are not black as
allies but today's civil rights leaders
are not interested
now Malcolm X actually won the the war I
think Martin Luther King won the battle
and Malcolm X won the war in a lot of
ways because now we have racial
polarization on all fronts not even late
Malcolm X like after Malcolm X became an
actual Muslim as opposed to a member of
the Nation of Islam and and started
talking about racial tolerance and then
got shot for his trouble by the members
of the Nation of Islam allegedly but
like early Malcolm X like white Devils
Malcolm X like there's a there's a
certain resonance to that in today's
politics that was supposed to be going
on a while ago well so this white
preacher there's this fellow Thomas
Oliver Thomas he continues along these
lines he says quote oh let tana he see
Coates boil it down for you first of all
you should never let tonic he see Coates
boil down anything for you Tana he see
Coates is a wildly overrated writer he's
a wildly overrated thinker I mean I
think the tiny he see Coates worldview
can be summed up by the fact that he
wrote in one of his pieces or in his
book that he during 9/11 who's sitting
on the top of his apartment building
watching 9/11 happen and he didn't feel
anything Tana heat c-code said quote
white so this is a from Oliver Thomas
white society was not achieved through
wine tastings and ice cream socials but
rather through the pillaging of life
liberty labor and land insured through
three centuries of kidnapping torture
murder and rape we built an entire
society on these bruised and broken
backs that and countless Native
Americans driven off their land I've
been asked to speak in a Martin Luther
King Day event me a white preacher
speaking to a predominantly black
audience filled with gifted preachers
well here's the message no white person
understands the black experience and
this is what the left wants you to take
away from Martin Luther King Day is that
you should judge people by the color of
their skin not the content of their
character and we can never have a
situation in which a little black child
and a little white child hold hands and
walk into the future together we can't
have that because the black kid can't
understand the white kid and mostly the
white kid really can never understand
the black head first of all this is just
not factually true obviously we should
rule Ament and to cry and remember the
absolute evils of slavery and the
horrors of Jim Crow but to suggest that
American power was built on the back of
slavery is economically illiterate
illiterate and morally obtuse it really
is slavery is not a an institution that
benefits that benefit societies
economically speaking it doesn't slavery
is actually backwards this is one of the
reasons why the north was wildly out
competing the South during the Civil War
I mean you would have imagined that the
side with all the slaves would have won
if slavery were all that great for the
economy slavery is not good for the
economy it turns out it turns out that
wages are much better for the economy
than slavery is so the idea that we
built our economic power on the back of
slavery is just not true we actually
built our economic power in spite of
slavery the great British Empire really
became the great British Empire after
outlawing slavery America got more
powerful in spite of slavery we got more
powerful in spite of Jim Crow not
because of Jim Crow one of the things
that a lot of the kind of revisionist
racialist like to say is America only
became powerful and wealthy because of
Jim Crow
are you kidding it turns out that taking
10% of your population and treating them
like animals is not good for the economy
it's not actually good for the economy
you're losing all of the intellectual
can forget about the moral issues
involved forget about the moral evil of
that you're losing all the intellectual
capital you're losing all the hard work
you're losing all the marketable skills
the Constitution in the United States is
great not because it enshrined slavery
permanently but because it was a step
toward abolishing slavery that's what
the Constitution was designed to do when
you hear people talk about the
three-fifths law and how racist the
three-fifths law was the whole purpose
of the three-fifths law in the
Constitution the whole purpose of the
three-fifths provision is because the
North did not want the south to be able
to vote for continuing slavery by
counting slaves as citizens for purposes
of allocation of votes they came up with
this compromise so they could actually
actually have a functional country but
the purpose of the three-fifths clause
was partially to get rid of slavery the
Declaration of Independence as Frederick
Douglas made clear was not because it
was particularly white people but
because it was universal Frederick
Douglas was very passionate about the
Declaration of Independence so all of
this is just historically not true but
it's the message of it that's really
gross so Martin Luther King did and the
reason that you know you're proud to
show videos of Martin Luther King to
your kids my daughter is a little too
young to understand it she's only just
turning 3 next week but as soon as she's
old enough to understand I'm gonna be
proud and honored to show her speeches
of Martin Luther King and at the at the
march on Washington because King
appealed to our common humanity's
individual human beings the the fact
that we could understand the black
experience even if we could never fully
experience it we can never fully
experience what anyone else in society
is going through I can't live somebody
else's experience that's not possible
but I can understand I can empathize
with what they're going through and that
allows me to realize
I can think about what it would be like
if I were they and then I can figure out
what exactly what exactly to do about
that that's the whole point common
understanding is necessary in order to
care anything if you're starting from
the point of I can never understand you
that actually leads to more tribalism
not less tribalism why would I care
about somebody I can't understand if the
species of alien came down and there was
no way to understand them would that
generate more sympathy or less sympathy
the whole purpose of establishing lines
of communication is to understand each
other better
this is counterproductive racially
Martin Luther King's whole shtick his
whole spiel was that individual decency
Trump's group grievance particularly for
white folks like white folks can't do
this group grievance routine against
black folks they actually have to treat
black folks as individuals and black
folks likewise have to treat white folks
as individuals so saying that all whites
killed Martin Luther King is just as
inane as saying all Democrats killed
Martin Luther King it's just as inane
and saying all Muslims are responsible
for every terror attack it's silly it's
counterproductive it doesn't actually
establish the ties that need to happen
in order to in order to achieve beyond
which Islam is actually a philosophy
white is not a philosophy it's a color
and the fact is the Civil Rights Act was
passed by a bunch of white people
the fact is Jim Crow was ended by a
bunch of white people yes it took black
leadership to do that thank God for the
black leaders thank God for people like
John Willis we'll get to in a second but
that doesn't mean that it didn't take a
coalition of people across racial lines
in order to reach success I mean if you
want racial reconciliation the reason
that Martin Luther King is a great
figure and Malcolm X is not a great
figure is because Malcolm X is Malcolm
X's perspective on race is
counterproductive and leads to
polarization Martin Luther King's
perspective on race is a deeply American
one a uniquely American one and that's
why we celebrate his birthday today
now meanwhile Donald Trump has been
elected president and of course that
means it's time for the left to
completely lose its freakin mind I mean
they've gone completely nuts
representative John Lewis led it off
John Lewis of course was famous because
he led the attempt to break a the
segregated segregation in the south
I was clubbed about the ears for his
trouble and so real civil rights hero
John Lewis but just because you know as
I get older one of the things that I
tend to realize is that there are no
heroes there are no villains
they're just people who do heroic things
and people who do the Lennis things
people are people are people but you can
say if somebody is a saint you know over
the course of their life then their
sayings over the course of their life
but a lot of people do heroic things
also say stupid things a lot of people
who do really villainous things also do
good things and it's easier as a human
being to label action rather than to
label people I'll say that John Lewis
was a civil rights hero he did very
heroic things during the civil rights
struggle that does not mean he's
anywhere close to right on what he's
about to say about Donald Trump here I
don't see this president-elect has a
legitimate president you do not consider
him a legitimate president why is that I
think the Russians participated in
helping this man get elected and they
helped destroyed the candidacy or
Hillary Clinton I don't plan to attend a
inauguration it would be the first one
that I miss since I've been in Congress
you cannot be at home with something
that you feel that is wrong that's gonna
send out it's gonna send a big message
to a lot of people in this country that
you don't believe he's a legitimate
president I think there was a conspiracy
on the part of the Russians in others to
help him get a liked it that's not right
that's not fair that's not open
democratic process okay so you know
whatever you think of the Russian
interference in the election the fact is
there is a legitimate vote held based on
the information that was available to
the public and Hillary Clinton lost so
John Lewis is wrong here so Donald Trump
naturally goes to Twitter to respond
manure his tweets Congressman John Lewis
should spend more time on fixing and
helping his district which is in
horrible shape and falling apart
not to mention crime-infested rather
than falsely complaining about the
election results all talk talk talk no
action or results sad hey there's that
typical Trump sad with the exclamation
point Congressman John Lewis should
finally focus on the burning and
crime-infested inner cities of the US I
can use all the help I can get so you
know is this typically subtly worded
Donald Trump no this is pretty typical
trumpet
not wrong about the fact that if this
were reversed everybody on the Left
would lose their mind right if this were
somebody saying that Hillary Clinton
were not illegitimate president in fact
when Donald Trump said that Barack Obama
was not a legitimate president that he
was born outside the United States
everybody rightly went nuts now
everybody's getting on Trump for this
and they're a bunch of people on the
Left who said that that Trump was
attacking John Lewis racially Nina
Turner who's a commentator on on CNN
former former Ohio state senator Nina
Turner this is what she had to say about
Donald Trump's response to John Lewis
well he's Congressman John Lewis I just
want to say that to make sure that we
gave him the record requisite respect
that he deserves and fifty years ago
everything that he did is still
important today now I as a Democrat we
know that the Russians had some impact
but they didn't go vote on Election Day
they didn't mess with the electronic
data so there are some Democrats to get
that and they didn't write the emails
Democrats are gonna have to wear that
but at the same time what the
president-elect needs to do this is not
the apprentice the White House edition
his tweets were insensitive for him to
categorize congressman Trump excuse me
congressman Lewis's district as as in
bad shape prime investor crime and
that's not by the way fortune 500
companies it's about 58% of house
American right
institutions of higher learning it is
diverse ethnically and it is diverse
economically so my memo to my to my to
my white elected officials not just a
president elect Trump but a light a lot
of white elected officials make this
mistake in making the African American
community a very homogenious they read
us the wrong way they think everybody's
poor everybody's broken down that is not
the truth so they need to come and visit
some African American community she's
implying that Trump is a racist because
he said that Lewis's district was
crime-infested and an in bad shape here
are the actual facts about John Lewis's
district is George's fifth congressional
district as compared to the state
average in the national average okay
here is from the Census Bureau the
unemployment rate in John Lewis's
district out of 2015 was 8.2 percent the
state average was 5.5 percent the
national average was 5 percent so is
there way higher unemployment in John
Lewis
district answer yes there is much higher
unemployment in John Lewis's district
okay when it looks at when you look at
the poverty rate the poverty is
seventeen point three percent in
Georgia's fifth District it's seventeen
percent state average 13.5 percent
nationally a little bit higher than the
state average a lot higher than the
national average now there are some
major businesses that are located in
John Lewis's district but the the crime
rates are also they are higher in John
Lewis's district okay so Atlanta is
located inside Lewis's district it had
the fourteenth highest violent crime
rate in the United States in 2015 with
1120 violent crimes per 100,000
residents which is triple the national
average that's triple the national
average okay so is Trump wildly wrong on
all of this no Trump isn't wildly wrong
on all of this should Louis be doing a
better job for his district yes he
should be doing a better job for his
district does one thing have to do with
another know it was it the way that I
would have phrased it no but to claim
that Trump is a big racist because he's
pointing out that Louis's district isn't
in the greatest shape ever that is a
stretch by the way he would say the same
thing about some white persons districts
right if a white person had insulted him
he'd have said exactly the same thing
and you know he would if you're on the
left you know Trump has no-holds-barred
if you if you attack him in any way he
is going to loose the hounds of Twitter
on you and that means that he's gonna
call your district crime ridden and it's
gonna be like compared to Mad Max and
and it'll just be Mel Gibson running
through the Australian wasteland
according to Donald Trump doesn't matter
I mean Mel he said Meryl Streep was an
overrated actress because she insulted
him at the Golden Globes do you really
think that if John Lewis were white he
wouldn't have said the same thing it's
just really silly all around but the
left is really attempting now to push
this notion that Donald Trump is an
illegitimate president we'll talk about
that a little bit more in just a second
but first I have to open my second gift
of the day I am so you guys you really
wrapped it up beautifully here so thank
you for that I'll never be able to guess
what this is oh it's your resignations
no it isn't no actually it's just it's
another ad thank you to our newest
advertisers over at Mack Weldon so Mack
Weldon makes just fantastic fantastic
stuff it's really comfort where it's its
underwear socks shirts undershirts
hoodie sweat pants and it all fits you
they have a line of silver underwear and
shirts that are naturally antimicrobial
which means that they they quash stench
which is which is definitely an
excellent thing they also want to make
sure that you are comfortable so all of
the all of their clothes are so
comfortable if you don't like the
clothes that they send you you can
actually keep it your first pair and you
can keep it and they'll still refund you
no questions asked
I've gotten a bunch of pairs of
underwear and and some some sweat pants
and a shirt from them it's SuperDuper
comfortable I can tell you I've been
wearing this pair of Mac Walton
underwear for at least last week and it
hasn't need to be washed it's fantastics
like Superman's underwear it's just it's
just tremendous but really their stuff
is really really good it's really
comfortable I really enjoy wearing it
and you will too it's I'm somebody who
as soon as I go home I put on the
comfort where I don't stay dressed up in
this in this just unbelievably snazzy
outfit as soon as I get home I throw on
my Mac Weldon and then I go work out or
I hang out and right and and it makes my
life much better if you really really
want to feel wealthy get some Mack
welding clothes because it makes you
feel luxurious in the way that you're
being lazy it's it's really fantastic
Mac Weldon com they look good by the way
you can you can workout or go to work
you can even in like their stuff is it
has a range it's not just for hanging
out at home you can work out in it you
can go to work in it actually a lot of
their stuff is nice enough for that Mac
Weldon comm get 20% off all of their
merchandise using promo code Shapiro
that's promo code Shapiro sh AP IRL but
you know that or you wouldn't be
listening promo code Shapiro Mac Weldon
comm get that 20% off and again their
product is awesome we couldn't be
prouder to have them as an advertiser
okay so final note before we have to
sign off here on Facebook and YouTube so
the left is fully invested in calling
Donald Trump illegitimate and the right
seems very perturbed about this oh it's
totally inappropriate for them to say
it's illegitimate that Trump is
illegitimate okay the left did it for
years okay the the left isn't it you
know they've been saying that they said
Bush was illegitimate they said that
they say that right now Trump is
illegitimate
every time a Republican is elected it's
illegitimate right everything is he'll
admit that the right does and it's it's
now coming from both sides right Donald
Trump said that Barack Obama was
basically illegitimate Paul Krugman who
just a week ago was saying that
Republicans are alienating too many
people in polarizing the political
discourse wrote a column
in which he said let's not talk about
mr. Trump's ravings instead let's ask
whether mr. Lewis was right to say what
he said is it okay morally and
politically to declare the man about to
move into the White House illegitimate
yes it is in fact it's an act of
patriotism so now we're back in the
space where dissent is the highest form
of patriotism blah blah blah blah blah
it's just amazing how the positions
switch as soon as the shoes on the other
foot as soon as Trump gets elected then
it's fine to say that the president is
illegitimate if the results had been
exactly the same and Republicans had
said Hillary is illegitimate she should
have been running she's a criminal
the left was a how dare you you accept
her she's your president she's your
president you accept that it's just
amazing there is no penalty by the way
for calling the president just on a
political note it's actually beneficial
we've reached the point in American
politics where casting the other side's
winners as illegitimate is actually a
very useful tactic it really the left
did this for george w bush for years and
years and years nancy pelosi did it for
years and years and years it was very
successful for her donald trump did it
for Barack Obama he was very successful
for him I think this is just part of the
new political discourse and we're all
gonna have to get used to it he's
calling the other side illegitimate no
matter what the actual results now the
only time I haven't seen that is with
Obama 2012 to Obama 2012 I didn't see a
lot of Obama is an illegitimate
president from the right even though he
had obviously lied about what happened
in Benghazi in order to prop himself up
at the end of the election cycle even
though the media were obviously propping
him up he was a legitimate president I
didn't see a lot of that from the right
but it's become sort of a ball to be
batted around
by both sides so none of this is
particularly surprising Dianne Feinstein
is also saying that Donald Trump is
illegitimate because Russia interfered
we've got a huge destruction of our
system going on so we have to we have to
be full and robust in this look and I
trust that we are I have worked with
chairman before a long time and I
believe that this can happen if it
doesn't we will sing out loud and clear
let me buttonhole something though you
said you believe that Russia's
interference altered the outcome of the
election I do I believe that
nation of a couple of things I think
that and I think the FBI in the October
Surprise I call it an October Surprise
of announcing a subsequent investigation
did have an impact and I believe the
Clinton Pizza invented to turn October
Surprise who knew but yes so the
Democrats are just gonna keep saying
this the Democratic chair candidate is
saying the same thing that Trump was
allegedly elected we can we can play
that as well
he's truth-telling I don't think this is
about just Democrats this is Americans
anyone with a smidgen of common sense
can remember Donald Trump looking in the
camera encouraging Russia to hack into
our electoral process cheerleading them
on and the idea that whatever
information these members of Congress
are getting out of this classified
briefing had them storm out of that room
makes it very clear that the decisions
that the FBI made that we runnin
unprecedented to get involved in the
election against Hillary Clinton pick a
winner pick a loser when they had so
much information that was so damaging
what have we been talking about since
this man was allegedly elected oh yeah
how coming haulage of knowledge that he
achieved the necessary electoral votes
and is legitimately elected president
United States would you not well I
haven't seen the classified briefing
that the member you and I won an
election might be asking as we continue
here on the bench Shapiro show is
whether this is good strategy or not cuz
there's a bit of a split opening up in
the Democratic Party we also got to talk
about Trump going out for SNL we got to
talk about Trump on Obamacare we got to
talk about Trump on NATO EU the
intelligence community Trump on we
have tons coming up like a lot and these
these guys work really hard to cut all
of this audio so you're gonna want to be
around to as we as we analyze all of it
because there's a lot to cover plus I
will do a full on spoiler a complete
review of la-la-land and so yeah I know
I'll spoil it for all you but I'll warn
you beforehand so we'll get to all that
but you have to become a subscriber it's
a Lee Weyer calm to see that live right
now over at Daily wire calm eight bucks
a month will get you that have a bunch
of goodies that are coming up right now
I am personally working on the goodie
bag that will be available to you and
20:17 as you become a subscriber an
annual subscriber go to daily wired.com
right now to become a subscriber eight
bucks a month you get access to the
mailbag as well so you can join the show
on Thursdays we're gonna have all sorts
of new stuff coming up we are the
largest podcast in the conservative
podcast in the United States check us
out at daily wire.com make sure by the
way if you listen on iTunes or
SoundCloud go to iTunes to give us a 5
star review because if you listen you
love so go to iTunes and and you can
review us there so make sure that you
cheat and do that for free but to
subscribe you go to daily wire calm
you